[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
donnerstag die vom sport hat norbert
lehmann angelo dammtor von mir wir haben
unter anderem diese themen für sie
hilferufe aus afghanistan frauen
verrichten dass die errungenschaften der
letzten jahre von den taliban zunichte
gemacht werden
wer brauchte eine krone auffrischimpfung
in bayern kamen heute die ersten
senioren dran für die meisten bürger ist
sie nach expertenmeinung noch nicht
nötig
verzweiflung in haiti nach erdbeben und
wirbelsturm kommt nur schleppend hilfe
an mehr als 300 menschen werden noch
vermisst
die lage am flughafen in kabul bleibt
dramatisch da sein menschenmassen und in
diesen massen müssten dann die gefunden
werden die ausreisen dürfen so
beschreibt es heute der für den
deutschen evakuierungseinsatz zuständige
bundeswehrgeneral in kabul das gleiche
der suche nach der nadel im heuhaufen
sagt er
und doch bleibt der flughafen die letzte
hoffnung wer sich auf den weg dorthin
macht begibt sich in lebensgefahr muss
vorbei an kontrollpunkten der taliban
selbst wem das gelingt der muss weiter
hoffen den us soldaten kontrollieren die
zufahrten an ihnen vorbei und in eine
maschine der bundeswehr haben es bisher
mehr als 1000 menschen geschafft glück
war bot
den ganzen tag über starteten
transportflugzeuge vom flughafen kabul
darunter auch bundeswehrmaschinen die
deutsche staatsbürger und afghanischer
helfer und deren familien ins
benachbarte taschkent nach usbekistan
brachten die lage an den außenmauern des
flughafens kabul bleibt aber gefährlich
chaotisch tausende afghanen versuchen
weiterhin verzweifelt auf dem luftweg
ins ausland zu gelangen die wenigsten
von ihnen haben pässe oder dokumente
bundeswehrgeneral alt der den deutschen
einsatz in kabul koordiniert fürchtet
dass die lage sich noch zuspitzen wird
menschen hat nämlich das gefühl haben
aufgrund der sorge dass ihnen die zeit
wegläuft sich aber vorstellen dass die
schüler für das fußballstadion dann
müssen die namen der im raum versuchen
dort jemand herauszupicken die zufahrten
werden von bewaffneten taliban
kontrolliert nur wer einen pass und
eindeutige unterlagen vorweisen kann
wird durchgelassen in der menge auch
menschen die aus der provinz vor den
taliban geflohen waren wie eine ärztin
aus hehlrath
die wollen frauen mit ihren kämpfern
zwangsverheiraten ich bin ärztin meine
schwester frauenrechtsaktivistin wir
sind in gefahr
im stadtzentrum von kabul herrscht heute
wieder scheinbare normalität händler
berichten von nahrungsmittel engpässen
weil viele lastwagen an der
pakistanischen grenze blockiert sind aus
mehreren städten wurden unterdessen
proteste gegen die machtergreifung der
taliban gemeldet bürger zogen zum
heutigen unabhängigkeitstag mit der
afghanischen flagge durch die straßen
die taliban setzten schusswaffen ein um
die proteste aufzulösen
augenzeugen berichteten von mehreren
toten
hermes gehört vor allem auch die frauen
in afghanistan haben angst was sie jetzt
erwartet eigentlich haben die taliban
versprochen dass sie die rechte der
frauen respektieren dass frauen weiter
arbeiten und studieren dürfen doch schon
wenige tage nach der machtübernahme
zeigt sich offenbar was von diesen
versprechungen zu halten ist an seinem
stern
kämpfer der radikal islamischen taliban
zurück in kabul zurück an der macht wie
aber werden sie herrschen vor allem bei
frauen wächst die angst von tag zu tag
die im land bekannte fernsehjournalistin
shabnam daran hat ab sofort
arbeitsverbot ich habe all meinen mut
zusammen genommen und bin zum sender
gegangen doch die soldaten der taliban
haben nicht nicht reingelassen du darfst
nicht geh nach hause wurde mir gesagt
ich bitte die welt mir zu helfen mein
leben ist in gefahr
verzweifelte nachrichten aus kabul
bekommt auch shafi kasan geboren in
kabul jetzt lebt sie in hannover kämpft
seit vielen jahren mit ihrem verein für
die rechte von frauen in afghanistan
ich habe einen anruf bekommen aus der
provinz herat hier haben die taliban den
mädchen gesagt sie dürfen nicht mehr zur
schule gehen witwen werden
zwangsverheiratet
kurz nach der machtübernahme hatten die
taliban versprochen es werde keine
schreckensherrschaft geben keiner müsse
sich sorgen machen viele glauben das
nicht fürchten die rückkehr der brutalen
unterdrückung
etwa nadja kwami vor jahren kam sie von
kabul nach frankfurt im minuten-takt nun
schlechte nachrichten
mitbekommen habe dass ein paar junge
frau und ein junger mann die taliban
erwischt dass die amt in hand auf die
straße gehen und dann haben sie
festgestellt dass die weder geschwister
sind noch vater mutter oder vater
tochter samt und haben die frau
geschlagen
freiheit ein selbstbestimmtes leben
bildung und chancen für frauen alles
errungenschaften der letzten 20 jahre
jetzt werden die schaufenster verhüllt
gesichter verschwinden aus angst vor den
islamisten die wieder die kontrolle
haben
warnungen und hilferufe aus afghanistan
gibt es schon seit wochen auch
deutschland hätte seinen ortskräfte viel
früher helfen können seit tagen wird
diskutiert warum das nicht geschehen ist
heute mussten der innenminister und der
chef des bundesnachrichtendienstes
stellung beziehen da wird gebaut hat
mehr sie haben es geschafft deutsche
staatsbürger und ortskräfte aus
afghanistan am morgen in frankfurt
während in kabul die rettungsaktion
schleppen weiterläuft
wer in der bundesregierung für dieses
chaos verantwortlich ist auch heute
wieder thema im politischen wellen der
innenausschuss lädt den innenminister
der so der vorwurf habe in den letzten
wochen hilfe blockiert
er hat darauf bestanden über wochen dass
die ob die ortskräfte erst dort gecheckt
werden dass man sicherheitsüberprüfung
macht das visa erteilt werden in
afghanistan anstatt die zeit zu nutzen
die menschen rechtzeitig aus afghanistan
nach deutschland zu bringen schon im
juni auf der innenministerkonferenz von
bund und ländern war eigentlich
verabredet worden die einreise vor
ortskräfte zu erleichtern der beschluss
sah unter anderem vor dass alle
vorkehrungen für eine beschleunigte und
flexible bearbeitung der gefährdung sun
zu eigen und des visum verfahrens
getroffen werden um den orts kräften
eine schnelle ausreise nach deutschland
so ermöglicht der bundesinnenminister
aber wie kein versagen seines hauses
ich sage wir haben zu einem frühen
zeitpunkt
klar gemacht dass an uns dem
ölministerium bäder ein charterflug
scheitert
noch
die visaerteilung in deutschland und die
sicherheitsüberprüfung in deutschland
jeder sagt jetzt er hätte nichts dagegen
gehabt dass in verschiedene ressorts die
da sagen ja von uns auswärts in ordnung
gewesen das finde ich ist ein punkt der
mich auch noch interessiert an dem es
denn nun eigentlich auch die
nachrichtendienste insbesondere der bmd
hatten die situation völlig unterschätzt
die bundesregierung will weiterhelfen
ist aber nur noch bedingt herr der lage
es ist traurig dass wegen dieses
zögerlichen unkoordinierten handelns da
jetzt verhandeln mit terroristen
notwendig ist die situation das nicht
tun es hat uns jetzt in einer situation
gebracht dass wir ab rest sind ablesbar
oder erpresst werden können
mit menschenleben die politische
aufarbeitung des afghanistan desasters
steht immer noch ganz am anfang auch von
einem möglichen untersuchungsausschuss
ist die rede nach der bundestagswahl
um 19.30 sprechen die kollegen von zdf
heute live mit einer aus afghanistan
stammende journalistin und einem
experten für entwicklungshilfe zu sehen
in der zdf- heute- app und auf zdf
heute.de jetzt zum corona virus da geht
die zahl der neuinfektionen weiter nach
oben das robert koch institut
registrierte
8400 neue fälle innerhalb von 24 stunden
das sind
2762 mehr als vor einer woche außerdem
wurden 22 todesfälle binnen eines tages
gemeldet die sieben tage incidents stieg
auf
44,2 in bayern bekamen heute die ersten
eine auffrischimpfung gegen das corona
virus über sinn und unsinn wird heftig
gestritten millionen menschen im armen
teil der welt sind noch gar nicht
geimpft kritisiert die
weltgesundheitsorganisation und der
virologe christian drosten sagt wir
brauchen diese auffrischung nicht außer
für alte und risikopatienten die sind
jetzt die ersten in bayern patricia
schäfer
eigentlich sollte darf erst im september
passieren in diesem bayrischen altenheim
wurde ist aber heute schon gemacht die
dritte corona impfung acht monate nach
der gärten
die bewohner sind froh über diese
möglichkeit und machen alle mit
noch gibt es keine empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission für dritt
impfungen aber das bayerische
gesundheitsministerium macht der anfang
der woche den weg dafür frei und dr
kurzen eck holte sich auch vom rk ii die
bestätigung dass er loslegen kann auf
eigene initiative weil ich eben glaube
doch das wird durch die delta mutation
sie tritt ihm von gott für risikogruppen
sehr sehr wichtig werden wird und da
wenn wir auch schwierigkeiten haben den
impfstoff unterzubringen
verfällt ist es glaube ich dass der
ideale zeitpunkt die gesundheitsminister
der länder hatten vor zwei wochen
beschlossen hochbetagten und anderen
wohlhabenden gruppen ab september eine
dritte impfung anzubieten es ist eine
entscheidung die man letztendlich für
die älteren menschen ohne solide
datenbasis feldmann würde aber vermuten
dass die älteren menschen die er sehr
früh geimpft wurden dann auch kein so
starkes immunsystem haben die ersten
sind bei denen auch die immunantwort
nachlässt und die man dann in eine
impfung mit einbeziehen sollte mit der
dritt impfung im altenheim marschiert
bayern in sachen corona maßnahmen mal
wieder voran eine empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission steht noch aus
der bundesgerichtshof hat heute einen
schlussstrich gezogen unter 1 der
dunkelsten deutschen kapitel der letzten
jahrzehnte währte treppe ist jetzt
rechtskräftig als mittäterin des
nationalsozialistischen untergrunds
verurteilt sie bleibt damit lebenslang
in haft
zwischen 2000 und 2007 erschütterte der
nsu mit einer rassistisch motivierten
mord serie die bundesrepublik die täter
ermordeten neuen kleinen unternehmer mit
migrationshintergrund und eine
polizistin
2018 fiel dann zwar ein urteil gegen
beate treppe endgültig ist es aber erst
ab heute christoph schneider sie
bildeten den sogenannten nsu die
verstorbenen uwe bernhardt uwe mundlos
und beate treppe sie ist die überlebende
des nsu trios musste sich in einem über
fünf jahre dauernden strafe fahren
gemeinsam mit vier unterstützern vor dem
olg münchen verantworten und bekam am
ende die höchststrafe eine lebenslange
freiheitsstrafe mit der feststellung der
besonderen schwere der schuld das geht
auch in ordnung sagt jetzt der bgh
der bundesgerichtshof hat die revision
der angeklagten schiffe und zwei
weiterer mit angeklagten als
offensichtlich unbegründet verworfen
damit sind diese verfahren rechtskräftig
abgeschlossen erleichterung bei
zahlreichen nebenklägern zumindest meine
mandanten zufrieden dass das
gerichtliche verfahren erstmal
abgeschlossen werden konnte unabhängig
von den anderen weiteren offenen fragen
insofern ist es auch ein guter tag ja
weniger gut findet beate chips
verteidiger dem beschluss des bgh
letztendlich habe ich mir aber doch eine
sehr realistische und auch hohe chance
ausgerechnet dass der bgh hier eine vom
olg abweichende entscheidungen treffen
wird doch der bgh sieht es im ergebnis
wie das olg
auch wenn jemand nicht am tatort gewesen
ist wie wertet schiffe kann man als
mittäterin verurteilt werden auch andere
handlungen reichen aus um einen mord zu
begehen bei beate treppe zum beispiel
dass sie eine wichtige rolle bei der
planung der taten gespielt hat und sie
ein starkes ideologisches interesse
daran hatte dass die morde auch gelingen
die letzte entscheidung zum fall nsu
steht noch aus die bundesanwaltschaft
will noch ein höheres strafmaß für andré
erwirken das olg münchen hatte den nsu
helfer zu zweieinhalb jahren verurteilt
über die revision wird der bgh im
dezember entscheiden
jetzt nach trier vor neun monaten raster
dort ein autofahrer mit seinem
geländewagen durch die fußgängerzone
fünf menschen starben 14 wurden schwer
verletzt seit heute steht der 51 jährige
mutmaßliche täter vor gericht
überlebende und angehörige hoffen auf
antworten susanne gelhard berichtet
bis heute ist die porta nigra in trier
mahnmal für die opfer der amokfahrt im
letzten dezember es ist die frage nach
dem warum auf die sich viele eine
antwort erhoffen auch der bruder eines
der opfer er sagt ich möchte dem
mutmaßlichen täter muss man ja noch
sagen mal in die augen schauen und ihm
einfach die frage stellen warum hast du
das getan wenn es da eine plausible
antwort gibt wäre es für ihn sicherlich
eine erleichterung
die tat geschah kurz vor 14 uhr im
vorweihnachtsgeschäft mitten in der
stadt es waren vier tödliche minuten die
trier erlebte laut staatsanwaltschaft
buch der angeklagte mit einem suv in die
fußgängerzone hauptmarkt und simeon
straße ein beschleunigte und vor gezielt
auf passanten zu in der nähe der porta
nigra hielt er an und wurde festgenommen
die staatsanwaltschaft trier wirft dem
angeklagten vor in fünf fällen einen
mord begangen zu haben in 18 fällen
versucht zu haben einen menschen zu
ermorden jeweils mordmerkmale der
heimtücke und des einsatz eines
gemeingefährlichen mitteln ein auto als
tatwaffe auch heute äußerte sich der
51-jährige angeklagte nicht zu seinem
motiv in trier werden jetzt bei vielen
erinnerungen wach war es ängste schon
mal denkt mal gucken was ist das für ein
auto was hinter dir ist es kamen dann
heute also auch für mich persönlich
jetzt dann wieder so richtig wohl und
habe gedacht meine heimatstadt ist der
vorspann bis januar sind zunächst
termine angesetzt es wird ein langer
prozess
mehr als anderthalb jahre nach dem
spektakulären einbruch in das grüne
gewölbe in dresden hat die polizei den
letzten tatverdächtigen festgenommen wie
auch die anderen fünf beschuldigten
stammt er aus einer arabisch stämmigen
berliner großfamilie gemeinsam sollen
sie aus der historischen schatzkammer
wertvolle schmuckstücke aus dem
siebzehnten und achtzehnten jahrhundert
erbeutet haben von den juwelen fehlt
jede spur
nach dem erdbeben in haiti ist die lage
dort weiter dramatisch inzwischen ist
von fast 2200 toten die rede und von
über 300 vermissten die hilfe kommt nur
langsam ins katastrophengebiet
am nachmittag ist ein expertenteam der
hilfsorganisation isar von deutschland
aus nach haiti aufgebrochen an bord
unter anderem medizinische ausrüstung
und zelte was die helfer vor ort
erwartet dazu ein bericht von claudia
bates
in den ländlichen gebieten geht es nicht
voran dörfer sind völlig zerstört und
auch fünf tage nach dem beben sind die
menschen hier auf sich selbst gestellt
versuchen in den trümmern weiter zu
leben aber wie soll das gehen
müssen wir denn schreien um von der
regierung gehört zu werden oder sollen
wir hier einfach sterben
trauer verzweiflung
die dringendsten bedürfnisse die das
gesundheitsministerium
identifiziert hat sind medizinisches
personal in die betroffenen gebiete zu
bringen und sie brauchen logistische
hilfe um hilfsmaterial herein und
patienten herauszubringen
aus dem ausland kommt jetzt diese hilfe
die us-küstenwache sitzt helikopter ein
um schwer verletzte in krankenhäuser zu
bringen aber es ist schwierig da unten
weil die zufahrtsstrassen teils
verschüttet sind und oft von bewaffneten
gangs kontrolliert werden aber es gibt
wohl eine art waffenruhe jetzt und so
ist auch mehr gerät eingetroffen um die
trümmer weg zu schaffen um die vielen
vermissten zu finden
noch viel zu tun für die
hilfsorganisationen
alles ist diesmal besser organisiert als
früher alle ziehen an einem strang es
geht auch recht schnell aber es bleibt
einfach zu wenig es ist ein tropfen auf
den heißen stein
tausende warten noch vor allem in den
zerstörten krankenhäusern wo die
verletzten gar nicht behandelt werden
können die internationale hilfe ist hier
ein hoffnungsschimmer
und jetzt der sport norbert die
paralympics stehen vorjahre am dienstag
geht es los in tokio 4400 sportlerinnen
und sportler aus 160 ländern werden
dabei sein das deutsche team das zählt
134 aktive der großteil von ihnen ist
heute von frankfurt am main aus nach
japan gestartet und wurde vom
bundespräsidenten
die deutschen haben große hoffnungen im
gepäck starten trotz der alarmierenden
coroner lage und einem rekord an
neuinfektionen in japan in ihr abenteuer
paralympics sie haben großes vertrauen
in eine strikte organisation der japaner
einfach die dankbarkeit
leben darf dass wir überhaupt diese
spiele haben dürfen bundespräsident
steinmeier gibt den athleten eine
persönliche botschaft auf den weg da
bitte ich einfach schon jetzt auch
wirklich stolz zu sein darauf dass der
weg nach tokio überhaupt möglich war zu
den besten der welt zu gehören am
dienstag beginnen die paralympics in
tokio mit der eröffnungsfeier
erfolgreicher start für olympiasieger
alexander zverev beim tennisturnier in
cincinnati
er besiegte den südafrikaner laut harris
in zwei sätzen und steht damit bereits
im achtelfinale sieben jahre in folge
hat es wäre es sein auftaktmatch in
cincinnati verloren und der
olympiasieger braucht geduld gegen den
aufschlagstarken lloyd harris bis zum
tie break machte er im ersten satz kaum
fehler und es braucht einen zauberhaften
passierball zum satzgewinn mit diesem
schlag ist der weg zum ersten sieg
geebnet wäre bleibt im zweiten satz
stabil dem südafrikaner dagegen
unterlaufen zunehmend fehler
dem ersten break folgt noch ein weiteres
und nach einer stunde und 16 minuten
beendet zverev mit einem ass das spiel 7
zu 6 und 6 2 er kommt mit der bürde des
favoriten bestens zurecht und steht im
achtelfinale an happy ich bin mit mir
selbst einfach in reimen und sehr
glücklich über den ersten sieg nach
sieben jahren
gegen den argentinier peya will er nun
weiter an seiner erfolgsgeschichte
schreiben
und darüber berichten wir morgen ja weil
ab morgen mittag erwartet uns ein turbo
sommer für 36 stunden das erzählt gleich
katja horneffer die zeit fürs heute
journal ist um viertel vor zehn mit
bettina schausten ihnen wünschen wir
alles gute und freuen uns wenn sie
morgen wieder dabei sind auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
auch heute gab es viele wolken über
mitteleuropa und die brachten auch regen
mit aber über spanien und frankreich
macht sich schon eine wolke bemerkbar es
gibt also mehr sonnenschein auch bei uns
in mitteleuropa am wochenende noch nicht
in dieser nacht ist es meist stärker
bewölkt und in norddeutschland fällt
aber etwas regen bei tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen 15 und 11 grad morgen liegen
die höchsttemperaturen an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee bei 19 bis 20 grad 20
bis 24 grad werden sonst und zwischen
dem mittel und dem oberrhein geht sogar
bis 26 grad morgen gibt es einen
streifen mit dichteren wolken hier vom
nördlichen brandenburg bis ins emsland
da fällt immer wieder regen da sehen sie
kaum mal die sonne und morgen vormittag
kann es richtung polen oder tschechien
auch nochmal für ein kurzes gewitter
erreichen wollen südwesten aber setzt
sich doch immer mehr die sonne durch das
wird eigentlich von stunde zu stunde
schöner und der samstag gibt dann in
ganz deutschland schönes wetter viel
sonnenschein 19 bis 29 grad vielleicht
morgens noch ein bisschen nebel die
wolken lösen sich auf aber am sonntag
kommt dann gewitter luft von westen
heran das sind gewitter mit hagel
platzregen und sturmböen also ein turbo
sommer mit 36 stunden haltbarkeit guten
abend